welcome to the weekly poll as usual
unbending the comic story and that is
Rob phasing out of reality comics
explained that is spouse his hair is
better than mine regardless of how much
stuff I try from its super effective
that is jewel one part of the 40-man
team that is comic book cast and that is
comic book you know I don't know her
well enough to make a joke so everyone's
channels are usual guys comic explained
in super effective comic book cast - and
comic Kuno you can easily look those
channels up I'll be posting them
periodically throughout the chat here
thank you guys for joining us today for
the weekly pull where it will now be
hosted every Tuesday and then eventually
the YouTube video will go up in Rob's
channel if you want to get live-action
chat make sure you come to twitch TV
backslash eligible monster every Tuesday
at 6 p.m. Eastern all right guys today
we're gonna talk about the Free Comic
Book Day books secret Wars
convergence divergence I mean the flash
ending out is it basically everything
for those of you guys want the know our
opinions on the Avengers we will be
doing another podcast at the same time
tomorrow discussing it but it will have
a crap ton of spoilers that is your
warning it will be spoiler filled
tomorrow okay so so what do we want to
talk about first we want a company that
virgins we want to do Secret Wars what
do you think why do we do like the
shortest topic fast and just start with
Suicide Squad costumes yeah you're all
about costumes like like it's like Faust
got in there like Benny was like what
are we gonna do for the topic so fast
was like suicide Suicide Squad costumes
I was like you and your costume I'm a
cosplayer so costumes are like always on
my mind like I'm always thinking okay
how could they have made that batch up
they could have done everything to make
those costumes that's oh my god is there
any of them like oh this was a little
bit better than this one or is all them
bad in your opinion I felt like so the
Suicide Squad is a team but all the
characters are very much individual like
they differentiate from each other
massively but all of those costumes can
they used similar color palettes and
that variant as the point completely
very sir military chic yeah like Harley
I'm Holly I'm sorry I'm Holly new 52 ish
Carly but even then they go in another
direction with it completely look like
tax although Killer Croc I thought was
the worst cuz honestly a girl it was
classic it was like the classic Killer
Croc Oh classic classic nothing dude
like fine with monster man croc I know
some people draw him is more reptilian
some people draw him more as a monster
for this you know pared-down
street-level universe monster man croc
yeah he looks like a Goomba from the
super what my opinion Hanukkah I like
the costume I don't think the girl looks
like Harley Quinn that's my odd like she
doesn't look like Harley Quinn she looks
like a model with makeup on and like I
don't get a sense of Harley Quinn she
looks like as much as I don't like
crappy Naga other cosplays because it'll
cost pies must love the characters but
she looks like one of those cosplayers
that goes oh my god I'm gonna cosplay
Harley Quinn I don't wanna put effort
into a costume so I'm just gonna use
stuff I already have and then cut some
rips in it and spot some paint on it can
I say I totally guessed this she wears a
jacket that we saw in another one it's a
jacket that says property of Joker on
the back can I just say that on my
pocket I totally predicted that only I
thought it would be a [ __ ] stamp that
said property Jo she can take it off I'm
actually a little disappointed on the
whole property of Joker now we obviously
don't know how much he's gonna be
attached to Joker but DC has done a very
good job of separating her from being
Joker's girl and it looks like the
movies gonna be like she's Joker's girl
and you're like again what's we just got
away from that fight well I think it's
maybe because the comics just have to
well the movie just have just to repeat
what we went through of the comics in
about 15 years really because I mean
people know who Harlequin is but not
really like people know her name and not
her origin stories I feel like you have
to do the Joker thing first and
separator hopefully and make this her
own movie I don't want to see that much
Joker in this film I want to see more
Hartley but wouldn't it have been better
if they came out the gate and like
Harley is her own person like they just
launched it with she has a history but
it's over that's exactly what I what I
thought that was that was the exact same
thing I thought the problem that I think
that people have with Harley Quinn now
and made they tried to fix this with
Holly Quinn solo series but it went on
for so long that I don't know if you
really can but it's like like Harley
Quinn and the Joker are like the one-two
punch of Gotham City like people think
of Harley Quinn I think of the Joker
people think of the Joker they think of
Harley Quinn and when one shows up
without the other people are like well
what's this that's weird like where's
where's Harley Quinn or where's the
Joker you know when people think of
Harley Quinn for example if they think
of her as solo they think of her as
Batman the Animated Series you know or
something like that and so I think he
was oh yes a great version yeah it's
it's I mean the original version the
best version I think honey but um you
know I think that that having if they
were to give her a separate character if
they were to say yes she's very much
intertwined with the Joker but she's not
a necessity for the Joker and the Joker
is not a necessity for her I think would
be a great way to like move her in the
direction of being an independent
character for right now in the comics
you got a Harley Quinn solo series which
is interesting enough but then they're
screwing it up with conversions and then
you've got Harley Quinn in Suicide Squad
which was decent enough but you know it
was Harley Quinn being a Suicide Squad
wasn't reason enough for me to run out
and buy the comic so yeah I mean I'm I'm
interested to see what they do I'm kind
of curious to see how they make her
character I quite liked how they played
her in the assault on Arkham movie
actually yeah no Isla I like that where
they established that she was there but
she was separating and they kind of
played it off maybe they'll do the same
thing with their they're on break
currently Joker and Harley are on three
exactly they're free to see other people
know seeing them together like it was
only five minutes but it's like all
right it told that Harley was with Joker
but you know Harley's her own they think
they could do it but at the same time I
don't know if I have faith in the DC
Cinematic Universe to do it but honestly
I'm super excited see Suicide Squad
here's the question here's the question
before they dropped it like a ton of
bricks in the new 52 they were trying
very hard to
romantically tie Deadshot Floyd Lawton
and Harley Quinn so much to the point
they prettied up Floyd law and in a way
that he never was before oh they tried
it for a bit and then they're like yeah
whatever and then they dropped it now
Floyd Lawtons back to being ugly again
with his big 70s porn stache you think
they're gonna try that in the movie
because I mean like hey that the rumors
flying around Margot Robbie and Will
Smith they were in which wasn't even a
horrible movie either so maybe my
biggest complaint about this is all the
other actors this is a good point look
like all the actors for the most part
look like they're playing a character
they don't look like themselves
Will Smith looks like Will Smith and
Will Smith plays Will Smith in every
single movie he'll play characters he
plays Will Smith and that is a big gripe
that I have because I was a working
actor for a long time
it's not [ __ ] hard to not play
yourself if you're being paid for it you
can play someone else and but then and
he's playing a comic-book character and
comment but characters are icons when
you're going into a comic book movie you
play the character you do not play
yourself out of respect for the source
material and that's just a huge issue I
have maybe he'll do it differently in
the movie but from that picture he looks
like Will Smith I think he's gonna play
it like I I get this weird feeling like
he's gonna play it very similar to how
he played like I am legends character
it's gonna be like that kind of a
character where he's like oh I'm gonna
save the day but I'll do what I want to
do you know that kind of guy maybe he'll
be Jim's West from a Wild Wild West
maybe he'll does that character off okay
I just wanted one thing if we're
launching on all of us watching Suicide
Squad would anybody really be upset if
in the middle of it he broke down into a
Suicide Squad Wrap on our own show
common is in the movie Will Smith is in
the movie they need to collaborate on
the greatest role Solomon is gonna be in
that movie
yes I really I want to hear I want to
see like mos def pop in for like like a
single verse yeah cuz it would be
freaking amazing like it's mos def
popped in like yeah I mean it's its
thing to do like like the squad just
don't understand
I'm on the fence about about Will Smith
I agree with Faust I feel like every
time Will Smith plays a role it's always
what would Will Smith be like in that
role like you know like this is what
will sir would be like if they went to
earth a thousand years after it was like
you know where people were ran out of it
you know I feel like Will Smith plays a
role like this is what Will Smith would
be like if he was a last man on earth
like this that's the role that Smith way
so I agree with that to a degree I mean
this even a movie that's what would Bill
Smith be like if he was a fish I think
as an actor you just I mean that's your
job like FASTA saying also and let's
hope Will Smith can play a different
character gear I yeah I mean I'm this
open that I'm just hoping the characters
are good because I mean costumes are
okay I feel they're they're okay but
drop it out we're losing someone we lose
Canada we lost cat I don't know how we
lost her I'm not even the one hosting
the internet anymore Rob she clearly got
assassinated by Deadshot for talking I
got back so I'm just gonna say I don't
remember what I said you can't drop your
camera real fast and bring it back so we
can try to get a rotating backing in
building a building off the whole
Deadshot thing it's funny for Will Smith
to take this role of what is essentially
a bad guy but I like even when he's a
bad guy he's got to play a guy who's not
totally back his flaw and he's
complicated and he does it for his
daughter and he's not really that much
of a scumbag he doesn't quite like the
other guys on his team because they're a
little bit more evil than he is yeah
well you know the same I have a Floyd is
as soon as they got rid of the moustache
they tried to give him like a character
yeah this Mike you don't mustache go
home for the longest time shave that off
now he's a good guy that was my favorite
version with that horrible mustache and
he couldn't dress and there's a great
bit where he's going on a date and like
knockout and banshee or trying to dress
him and he's wearing like this horrible
used car salesman suit I'm like oh
that's good stuff and I'm gonna be
honest
Kitana being
makes me feel slightly uncomfortable I
mean I mean she was in the suicide squad
long time ago like just after her run
and the outsiders I don't think that
that was the katana that they're using
there I think that was a different
character that went by katana so I don't
know it makes me feel really
uncomfortable random I feel and also I
mean you could go back to the TV shows -
like you have katana and arrow and I
mean this is the big thing about the DC
Cinematic Universe and their TV universe
we need a repetitiveness of having
katana in two places I don't think so
can we need a Flash movie definitely not
because we have a blasty video that's
like a whole different katana couldn't
even keep us solo comic so does she
really need to be in a movie and a TV
show I will say this know her her
parents adir arrow has nothing to do
with that character really like I'm not
even like I wasn't even aware that it
was katana until like halfway through
the season I'm like that's guitar I mean
I personally feel like if they really
really want to use katana that badly
make a birds of prey movie yes please
yes please
Gail Simone her life yes please so I
mean I think I think we all agree we're
all excited about it but we're all kind
of like on the fence as to where this is
really gonna go and what's gonna happen
with this so I mean I like we totally
talked over Jai Courtney as we should
cuz it's like Jai Courtney who sam
worthington 2.0 you don't say so um well
my problem my problem with the cast of
Suicide Squad is it's huge like I got a
really really feel like it's gonna be
handled like Avengers 2 without
reporters and without going into a
discussion about it there was just so
many people on it that no one got using
the same squad in nine members Adam
beaches Slipknot 8 making I'm gonna say
that right is gonna die in the first
five minutes you mark I mean I feel like
that's gonna be the inherent problem
with this with this movie I'm like I
think this movie is it's DC like in
desperation mode like oh my god like
Marvel's got all these movies and we got
to cash in you know I get on this cash
cow of like cinematic movies so they're
like you know what let's just take like
a whole bunch of no names and just like
or what to name characters from the
comics anyway throw them into like the
Suicide Squad like they used to do in
the comics
and then let's just like release like
nine people at one time and let's have
like Tom Hardy and let's have like Will
Smith and let's have Carmen and
something like that like well oops Tom
Hardy dropped out which is reason enough
for me to second-guess whether or not
the film's worth going to going to see
but you know the fact remains that that
that I I agree I think it may be too
much at one time I think this was gonna
have a very like spider-man 3 feel to it
like there's so much happening in such a
short amount of time anybody's all over
the place and it's like alright I don't
understand what's going on I think their
films and that's why it's an I think
every single movie's gonna feel rush
which is really upsetting so I want to
see a really cool DC film and I wanna
see Suicide Squad might be that one but
you guys are totally right it's a huge
cast myself thinking yeah he's
automatically in tonally with Suicide
Squad what's the big complaint no DC was
a guy why did this have to be so dark
and gritty at least Suicide Squad is
inherently dark and gray that's the
rumor that's floating about they're not
doing it documented everyone fighting
about is they're doing their own version
of guardians of the galaxy but in
Suicide Squad oh come on man the Suicide
Squad is the suicide like here's what I
was hoping I was hoping the Suicide
Squad would have like a sucker punch
feel to it like I would go watch it
would be really cool like sit down and
watch Suicide Squad and it feels like
Zack Snyder's sucker punch that would be
a like a great movie to see but if it's
gonna be like guardians of the galaxy
I've seen that do something different
they don't know how to do something
different and when they did with the
Green Lantern movie they flopped to do
anything that's not great in serials and
that's why we cut the man a train wreck
so I I don't know like that just scared
them into trying anything different
Superman didn't need to be dark Batman
vs Superman you're gonna need a huge
contrast in light versus dark
Suicide Squad does need to be [ __ ]
dog I don't know the assault on Arkham
was not a very dark movie I mean it had
its moments but I felt it was more
comical than dark feel honestly I wish
they saved that script for Suicide Squad
pretty good movie
you know I want to see it I want to see
my girl Amanda Waller where's my girl
Amanda what I'm saying man like I was
looking at that and I was like I want to
see like Amanda Waller Suicide Squad I
want to see your show up and saying you
guys go out there don't get killed do
you want do you want hot and skinny and
sexy man hawala or do you want a large
Oprah fat I real are large Oh professor
series
let's go the extra mile I want playing
Amanda Waller I wanna see like big
Amanda Waller
like you know she's authoritative but
you also know that like Saturday
mornings she cooks a damn good breakfast
like that's the amount of the comments
agree they want Oprah for Waller so I
could buy Oprah Winfrey in real life
actually has a black ops team of death
row inmates imeem she does have the own
network and she says it's to show that
we all own that network but no it's
Oprah just reminding us that she owns us
she rules the world
she is the Illuminati the one channel
says but I could own every chapter the
wall and you don't screw the big o no
but but no I think that I think Amanda
Waller is a great anchor for the Suicide
Squad because if if they introduced a
Suicide Squad and they say well it's
just a bunch of guys who just happened
to come together and they're just
operating as a team and it makes it seem
disjointed it makes it seem like they're
just kind of running around doing
whatever and there's no rhyme or reason
for why it's happening but if they bring
in Amanda Waller even if the entire
movie is Amanda Waller and the first
like ten minutes saying go do this and
they spend the whole movie doing that at
least it gives it like a basis it gives
us a foundation
which many Suicide Squad comics
absolutely are there's a great line in
the Young Justice show where she shows
up briefly where she's like prepping the
prisoners and she's like I'm not your
mother I'm not your maiden aunt I'm your
warden I like it I like like that's what
I want like the sassy you know no holds
barred you know see what I tell ya like
that's that's the amount of Waller that
I think a lot of things love and like I
said you know to have like a like a
solid you know authoritative figure like
that directing this band of criminals
makes sense otherwise it just seems like
it's just a bunch of lawless group of
criminals who just kind of happen to be
doing the right thing but not really you
know and so it's it's you know it
depends on how they do it but I'm afraid
that given what I've seen so far with a
lot of the DC live-action movies that
they're just gonna say well these guys
just came together by happenstance
Viola Davis she the one that plays
Amanda Waller and arrow from how to get
away with murder
oh dude if she's playing Amanda Waller
that's the kiss like she is amazing yeah
she's a pounder because I get the voice
actor from assault on Arkham she was a
she was let's see it's it's funny it's
funny when you think about that because
I think like a lot of times we look like
like looking at Suicide Squad looking at
Amanda Waller well The Suicide Squad
wasn't really featured in any of the
Justice League animated series don't
think like okay but like like we look at
Amanda Waller and we say like that is
Amanda Waller like that's the Amanda
Waller I know I mean she's like the
Amanda Waller in the comics I mean you
know she's very similar until you know
with the exception of you know how she
presents herself you can only go so far
and an animated series gear for kids but
you know the fact remains that that is
the Amanda Waller we know and so when
you sit down and you say which version
of a Noir do you want you want the one
in arrow know like do you want the one
from like the animated series yes
the character in the comics and
something they've kind of missed in the
latest Suicide Squad rumor that's a
train wreck of a whole nother sort it's
this idea that Waller is a morally
complex character she's not a hundred
percent good or evil she is a civil
servant given a dirty job by an uncaring
government and she's gonna finish it
however she sees fed but you like that
element or you don't like that I love
that element okay okay yeah I was like
that's a really cool element to have I
mean like previously if I remember
correctly because I don't remember a
whole lot from Amanda Waller Suicide
Squad from like volume Volume one I
think you know leading up until like now
actually I think originally she was a
character who was who was very
authoritative but she was working for
the government and like treated
basically treated the suicide squad
members like crap like you know and okay
that that's that's what I thought um
that one I think is kind of interesting
like she seems more like a villain if
anything you know and in the early
stories if what they've made her out to
be now because honestly I haven't even
touched the current run a Suicide Squad
I wasn't okay like if if a presenter now
is like this middle of the road like
on-again-off-again villain slash hero
I'm talking like the ostrich or stuff
where she's like okay where's I I'm bad
but everyone else is much worse than I
am
and you you need me I am a necessary
evil to save the country and to save
okay yeah yeah yeah I remember that from
you okay I remember like seeing that
character in Austrian run up until like
92 or something like that I think is
when you stopped writing it but like
yeah that was that was cool like I like
that element of Amanda Waller like I'm
talking about like right now no no if
this version now is just a lame
watered-down version not too bad she's
literally half the woman she used to be
I mean I was following the Suicide Squad
book up until recently Joel come back
please thank you I'm not gonna lie I
kind of steered away from Suicide Squad
for a little while they brought me back
by bringing on reverse-flash and then
blowing his knee up because he ran too
fast that was fine better it's gotten
better currently or at least it's gotten
like you know so grindhouse it's
actually pretty good like like you said
reverse flashes legs
below they go to China and fight evil
clones I hear they're gonna actually be
fighting Isis later at well you know
what you know what I love about
reverse-flash though is they don't call
him reverse-flash they call him not
flash or not flash broke his leg they go
not flash so what they did was they
brought in a new team and they had black
mantle running and he's joined up
because he wanted to to redeem right a
very stupid reason that Black Manta was
on that team he decided that he just
wanted a reason cuz he has no reason to
fight ah Q man anymore and they've gave
hit them reverse-flash but he lost a lot
of his power when flash sucked it all
out of him and the run so he was on the
team ain't like that he's running he's
running to Lee gotta run faster he runs
faster and his knee just blows out but
if the Daniel west version not be abarth
on version yeah yeah it's the new
version so and that's why they've never
officially called him reverse-flash he's
always been a new West the black was on
your mind to watch black with the red
face he's like the black spiky monorail
stuff yeah yeah and I'm gonna be
changing that team up again poison ivy
is gonna be on and like black hand and
parasite are gonna be on it for this run
I don't know how you could have black
hand I don't like zombies go because
like Suicide Squad was always d-list
expendable villains like well now you're
filling the team up with a and B list
villains you can't kill these guys
suicide was so we'll know Suicide Squad
was still well known for is it like my
characters like Deadshot and like
Captain Boomerang and stuff like that
we're like these like super obscure
almost you know totally unknown villains
that like came to the forefront with
Suicide Squad people were like holy cow
Deadshot this guy's lost at the same
time that was why it was such a great
idea to bring in Harley Quinn because
before the new 52 yeah she was she was
known for what being the Joker's
girlfriend she had that run and Gotham
City sirens and [ __ ] and she had her own
comic for a little bit but a little bit
Gotham City Cyrus I think was one of the
best things I ever did with Harley Quinn
the whole reason for that was because
like up until that point he was Harley
Quinn's Joker like that was there but
till I pair her up with with Oh God
poison ivy and Catwoman right this whole
adventure where they basically the whole
whole one was the three of them trying
to break out of the molds they had like
when we're at where some straw
independent women we don't need no man
screw you man sir you Joker this poison
ivy screw you swapping out of who she
marries a woman a Harley Quinn we're
both trying to break out of the molds if
we're just the girls that follow the
guys I don't know what poison ivy was
things through you nature and like
watching TV but but nature is a mother
though I don't understand you screw you
blades of grass like there were three
strong independent women and they went
on a road trip to California to played a
role in a movie in a science crappy
movie that's all this week in the new 52
they're actually pushing poison ivy into
more of our heroic direction she has an
alligator on anything to fill in isn't
quite like it I do it kind of matches up
a Swamp Thing and everything like it's
easy cuz she's an eco-terrorist and then
they can switch this well no she's just
more of an extreme eco person we're
gonna lose the terrorists and as long as
you lose a phrase terrorists it's not
really violence so much as it is like
you know Oh strong ideology I mean I
feel like I've always felt like I'm
poison ivy shouldn't necessarily be a
hero but shouldn't necessarily be a
violent you should just being like this
weird role of she does what she has to
do to get what she wants and if someone
gets out along the way then sorry
have a tree have a tree chaotic neutral
yeah we're gonna go D&D times is that
really what we're gonna do now super
nerd Joel I mean here's usually here's
the weird thing about poison ivy there's
something that I've never really really
got a whole lot with her character if
her character is rooted in nature itself
and she sees herself as a mother nature
itself as she's nurturing and caring for
all aspects of nature trees and and
grass and she's the one behind the
happening like M night Shyamalan movie
like if she's the person you know that
does all that stuff you know nobody
laughed at my joke for whatever
you know if she's appreciated that's
behind all that stuff then why would she
care about the goings-on of anybody
who's not doing anything other than
impeding on you know or I guess causing
problems for nature if if someone is
logging then of course you probably care
about that if somebody's dumping
chemicals into a river she's gonna care
about that
if someone's robbing a bank of what
relevance would it be to her I mean what
okay that's like that's like the
flimsiest connection okay at the same
time what would she fight like is it oh
my god you stood on an ant you need to
die boy well honestly what is swampthing
fight I mean that's all he's about
protecting the swamp oh my god evil did
not thank you there was a great issue of
Gotham Central where like all these
Street kids were getting harassed by
these dirty cops and we eventually go to
like Poison Ivy's green house we find
out that she's been like taking care of
all these street kids and like growing
food for them to eat and then she tricks
the dirty cops into coming in thinking
it's a meeting with Black Mass and then
she like hangs them from by instant
stuff it was good got from central rocks
it's better so so we've been talking
quite a while about Suicide Squad and
somehow we're just done a total tangent
about what poison ivy really is so let's
move on to our next topic that's us we
can do so much DC let's move over to the
Secret Wars which have officially
technically kind of have not really
started I don't understand why they
called it Secret Wars zero like it had
nothing to do with Secret Wars it was
basically Valerie Richards being like
malaria Richards being like hey we have
a raft okay so here is my biggest
question how old is Frank Franklin
Richards now cuz I thought he was eight
but there he had to have been at least
14 oh it's like he bounces around all
the time like like I remember when I was
doing the whole like Franklin Richards
explained that was a thing that got me
that most like there's one point where
he ages himself to like a full-grown
adult he like he makes himself Jesus
any point were like Headey ageism stuff
like once that's done he ages back and
it resets his aging so now he's younger
than he was before he aged himself and
then like he goes on like that he grows
for a few years and then suddenly he's a
kid again like you're in future
foundation he was younger during future
foundation that he was like previously
in continuity so weird they've even
valeria her origins is off to Zolo i
shoot the daughter dr. doom and then she
got rebirth the web or whatever it's
like there's music school kids what do
you expect I mean there's only one thing
sentence done about Valeria that they
keep saying is she will never have
powers no she can never have powers she
does have powers yeah she neutralizes
Franklin's powers wait that's it that's
like the Wonder Twins one of them turns
into water the other one turns into
ferocious animals I'm a bucket of water
and I'm a tiger you were useless in
genetics on that one there was there was
an episode of a Harvey Birdman attorney
at law where the wonderful in returns on
the water the guy he was talking about
how like like all the members of the
Justice League were gone except for the
the Native American dude and Apache
chief and and and Birdman was like you
happen to have expressed knowledge of
the whereabouts of like Wonder Woman you
know and he was like yeah he's like she
was taking a bath he's like how did you
know that hold on when I call it you got
a stick your hand up there wonder twin
powers activate back for like Justice
League 3000 how weird is that
Oh No so so now we're totally not a
crack on DC again the Wonder Twins are
technically DC you guys could we go back
to zero wars and Franklin Richards and
all okay so so here here was a funny
here was a funny question like I didn't
like the way Hickman did this I mean but
Hickman didn't really have a choice you
know because unless you were to create a
whole nother side story and my thought
about Hickman I don't know exactly how
he how he writes I don't know if maybe
he just plays it by ear if he plans like
a month ahead of time or what but I feel
like he sits down and he says okay
like I'm gonna be writing time runs out
so here's like three years worth and
like in this grandiose story and he has
it all him you know pinned out and
planned out and written down and
everything I have no idea that's the
case I just I'd like to think that's
true I don't think he did well I think
there was an overall plan I do agree to
that like then we're going to have the
incursions happen we're gonna have this
happen Tony Stark and cath America are
gonna fight and they're gonna argue and
we're gonna have dr. doom be the guy
behind it all but what I think it was
was like here's my arc and then Marvel
is like uh uh make that into three years
cuz these definitely moments in that
where it's like like he's dragging like
dude New Avengers I think 13 to 21 is
literally just looking at alternate
realities like nothing nothing happens
like like like number 13 is like Reed
Richards saying hey like we've created a
way to look at other realities and all
the other ones are just these other
realities yeah and that's what they do
like how many issues of looking at other
realities yeah once infinity ended the
entire thing up until a name or blew up
the first world was nothing but
alternate realities and he blows up the
first world in issue 24 and I'm pretty
sure it's like 22 and 23 and they fight
the Justice League guys and every issue
before that is them looking at other
realities and how they cope with it yeah
I think had we had the black priests and
stuff but he could have easily explained
a black priest without having without
having an expandable II seven or eight
issues whatever was the black priests
were just but like even in the fight he
look I totally think he made them up for
filler because when he when they go
through the explanation and the last
issue of New Avengers the doom
explaining everything he literally says
what about the black priests oh I don't
really know what they are I think it was
the multiverse fighting against what I'm
doing yeah that was that about that
that's true yeah he's like he's like
they're they're they're a consequence of
the multiverse will collapse and done
and done that's it or anything what they
are the mapmakers were given an
explanation with a black preacher like
nah know what he should have said was I
needed to fill a few issues so I made
another villain you don't would have
made a whole lot more sense if he'd have
said like these are all alternate
reality versions of like
Charles Xavier or something like that or
like alternate reality versions of
Doctor Strange himself but no one of the
one of the things I didn't like and like
I said I think Hickman was back into her
corner here was was the big question of
Franklin Richards because one question I
saw being asked everywhere like on every
form all over the place is if Franklin
Richards can work reality why isn't he
stopping the incursions why is it that
as soon as a reality pops up he just
goes to that alternate reality he phases
that earth out of existence comes back
and says okay and that's it so many
characters that kills a lot of people
that could do a lot of different things
I mean by the time a thing comes to an
end they find a way to phase a planet
into the planet Earth as like this layer
of protection so that when the Shiar
show up and like attack the planet Earth
nothing happens and then they use a
Dyson Sphere and annihilate the entire
Shiar fleet like all that and like
Franklin Richards can fix what was going
on but that that be the question because
the problem here is if Hickman came out
and Hickman said oh my god there's a
random incursion there's no one there to
save it so Franklin Richards just like
fixes it with a snap of his fingers and
fans are gonna say well why didn't he do
that the entire Franklin Richards was
killed in time runs out off panel and
all's we got was a scene of river just
holding him being like we've tried
everything he tried everything I don't
think I mean did he die weird is he
still alive
yeah but Fantastic Four is sever weather
weather killing them off which by the
way the end is forever is absolute
garbage is it it's terrible it's one of
the worst stories I've ever read also
just nothing actually got accomplished I
think here's a here's what I think the
end end is forever was like I think the
end is forever was marvel were like
let's just grind this into the ground
like let's just destroy any desire to
read this series any further that's
exactly what it was they salted the
Fantastic Four and no one's gonna go by
those comics again like but I mean I
wouldn't like I'll call you never go
pick up the Fantastic Four come
I don't feel bad that I haven't never
picked him up I never picked up with
Vanessa for karmic outside of it being a
part of an event I know I'm just a price
that you didn't read fantastic well 1 2
3 4 no grant morrison run no I never
read any fantastic for like I really I
mean you know you don't need to like yes
future foundation Hickman's run a future
foundation is almost as good as time
runs out like it's it's free it's pretty
stellar but let me tell you something
people talk about the relative the
relevance of the fantastic for fantastic
for this is fantastic for that the
fantastic for stop being relevant in the
1970s and the reason why was because
Spiderman was and was ahead of like a
major not really a major but he was like
God I think ground with a lot of fans of
Fantastic Four he was like can I be a
member the Fantastic Four and they were
like nope he went to try to become one
of the Avengers instead you know
characters like God who else was
featured in the Fantastic Four the
Inhumans appeared in the Fantastic Four
like there were a lot of different was
Marvel's platform if Marvel wanted to
introduce a character routine and they
wanted to see if it would be popular
like Panther they would put him in the
Fantastic Four because everybody was
reading the Fantastic Four and so if
fans where the Fantastic Four and like
wow Black Panther this guy's cool Black
Panther gets his own series if they
introduced the Inhumans to people like
wow the Inhumans are cool this guy never
talks I wonder why but the solo series
is absolute garbage so it didn't really
matter like people are like wow and
humans like they go and they they start
reading Inhumans Fantastic Four were
relevant for catapulting and launching a
lot of early comic books stories and
characters and teams and so on
once they gain their own ground once
like the inner circle of the comic book
and comic books of Marvel Comics Spider
Man the x-men fantastic the Inhumans all
those guys once they gain their ground
and they were solid and firm and going
in their own stories there was no need
for the Fantastic Four anymore and
that's why like over the course the
entire Fantastic Four continuity they're
almost never relevant because they're
not fighting like they're not fighting
the major things it's not like you read
you know infinity and it's like well oh
my god like the offenders are being
destroyed and like the x-men are nowhere
to be found and like the incursions are
happy
the Illuminati are dealing with the
builders of an alternate reality like
who's going to save us and Reed Richards
is like we are no one yeah the Fantastic
Four like no one thinks that well isn't
the problem the Fantastic Four is that
everything every time I've ever tried a
Fantastic Four book they're never even
on six one six it's like we're
time-traveling we're dimension-hopping
yeah we're fighting mole people those
map fractions run use in space on a
family trip and they time travel so you
know thank you like age of Ultron like
age of Ultron starts and the Fantastic
Four are out in space and like Black
Panther calls up Reed Richards and is
literally like hey man like Ultron's
laying waste to the planet you might
want to come back and Susan storm and
Reed Richards are like okay and they
leave Franklin and valaria on the ship
out in space they go to earth and Reed
Richards dies and Ben Grimm dies and
Susan storm is like left and we know how
the whole thing plays out with her like
that's literally with the Fant love what
happened the Fantastic Four as bad
parents I remember the Dark Reign tie-in
that I really loved oh where it's read
sitting in his room be like I gotta stop
the Civil War gotta find a reality where
the Civil War didn't happen and sue and
everyone else is out sounded like Reed
take care you babies take care of your
children read and then Norman Osborn
Kicks down the doors like I've taken
your children now cuz I'm evil I mean
like during Hickman's run of the Future
Foundation like there's that room where
Reed has like nothing but equations on
how to solve the world's like solve the
problem of everything like that's the
whole basis of the Council of Reed's
resist like I want to solve the problem
of everything and so then he finds a
council of reeds and they're like hey
all of us abandon our families and Reed
Richards is like I'm not gonna do that
and then lo and behold Matt Celestials
Franklin Richards makes colada but that
was probably the most awesome scene like
the awesome most awesome point in that
whole run is when Galactus is like
totally defeated by the mad Celestials
that combined into a single being
and then Franklin Richards like makes
him his Herald like he brings him back
to life and then like empowers him gives
him more power and then has him fight
like the Celestials that was probably
one of the coolest moments them and like
all the Fantastic Four's continuity but
whatever I mean my issue of the
Fantastic Four is I love Susan storm and
I love Reed Richards I don't like them
together I think my favorite time is
when they split up during civil war and
I was like yes finally they're really
the only couple that's even still
together about the same time they're
more boring and let's say Mary Jane and
Peter Parker we should get back together
Mary Jane holds back Peter Parker
superiors better improved at this
statistically and every time Peter and
Mary Jane are together it does not work
exactly work out for Peter Elise you
should have Mary Jane but one day it
could is the thing that's the hope we
all hold on to maybe this time will be
the right time I'm Charlie Simon but
whatever you know I mean everyone I like
Ann Marie I think you should start
dating and marina she's great I mean and
so many people were like oh yeah Pizza
should date spider-gwen yeah his date
Spidey when I was like he should only
date spider-gwen if they're gonna kill
her off in the exact same way
yet again just for the irony I mean
she's in college and he's like what 30
something like 34 years I think she's
like 19 she's like going to college like
she just graduated high school so that
would be kind of awkward you know he's
35 he's like this isn't wrong in any way
shape or form you know like my
girlfriend older but they stay the same
don't worry everybody they still draw me
like I'm 22
so so here's all right so here's a big
question that I would ask and we have
like Secret Wars number one coming out
tomorrow so I guess we'll find out but
with regards to the like the end of time
runs out Captain America and Tony Stark
are still fighting and the Ultimate
Universe is now like invading the main
Marvel Universe right
full-scale like full-scale invasion Nick
Fury's like sorry about their luck one
of us got to go in an angle me me so I'm
really curious to see I'm really excited
to see how that turns out this is
probably summoned like this is one of
the most exciting moments I've had in
the history of Marvel's continuity with
like all the stories that I've read I'd
say this is probably the baddest
sighting as I was when I was going
through and reading like I don't know
how come we all talk over each other the
entire podcast Foskey to get a word in
edgewise finally there's a lovely moment
where Rob's is done talking and
everyone's like no I'm just excited as
what as excited as ever what exciting is
ever happened in like like this high
time Marvel did this like that's I I say
it time and time again this is why I
give DC kudos DC said okay you know what
whatever like older fans are gonna be
pissed
who cares let's just reboot everything
and so they did it and it was number
ones and it was Superman start with
Action Comics number one is Superman
number one and that's it that's all you
needed start with Batman's ex nighters
run and I guess read read what do you
call it The Killing Joke like that's
really all you I mean that was really
cool stuff like it's do it but I would
say like with Marvel it's high time they
did that it's high time Marvel came
along and said in some former fashion
where reset in the continuity what I'm
hoping here is Marvel is gonna come back
and they're gonna say okay here's
earth-616 like as we know that we're
gonna have ultimate the ultimate
universe and the earth-616 existing like
side by side on some chunk of land and
the Inhumans are going to be there
I hope they're going to say there's like
10 people who survived the multiversal
collapse and the Earth's 160 Valerius
said in the zero issue their ship can
hold 6000 years obey your favorite is
one of the 60 they're gonna be there to
be taken like a lot of scientists and
stuff and so like we know they'll take
Amadeus Cho we don't like okay the top
10 smartest people so Reed Richards Tony
Stark Amadeus Cho Bruce Banner they he
said that he he dropped himself out he
ain't going anywhere he's only gonna be
part of Planet Hulk anyway so I guess it
weren't a me not from the x-men he can
come all the way hopefully I don't even
know if she's still around anymore miss
sage sage would be a good person to have
like like there's a handful of people
that they could bring in there but I'm
hoping that there's gonna be enough to
where they're gonna have like just like
a whole bunch of cushing and they're
gonna have like 10 or 11 people that you
actually care about like you know
spider-man will be there and they'll say
okay here's the backstory of spider-man
covered over the course of like this one
issue and that is spider-man has worked
and that's basically spider-man 0 issue
number one or whatever you want to call
it I just had a thought the way that you
described like oh they're probably gonna
bring scientists someone like getting in
this raft and then when I start Xavier
coming back from the dead and they have
to kick someone out because I've been
doing a lot of these origin videos DC is
super easy because they always retell
the origin regardless of whether or not
you like the new origin they've given
that is the new origin that is the
current continuity origin so the problem
with Marvel is they don't do that so
like I'll sit there and I'll do an
origin of the Green Lantern it's like
here it is you don't you like the only
one better that's cool but here's the
current origin but when it comes to
marble it's like ok so since it's not in
one issue we now have to go here's what
happened in 1960s here's what happened
in the 1970s this part was condensed
down because this is part of his horde a
Hawkeye was the worst cuz he got his Oh
his origin is the same origin but like
they just keep adding in moments as to
what happened and that's what happens is
most of the superheroes in Marvel and
they're doing it again to with hawkeye's
origins are retelling it again right now
yeah yeah and the problem is is that
instead of doing it like DC where
they're just like look here's the new
origin if you liked the old runs they
still exist but it's not in the origin
more Marvel likes to go everything has
happened now you need to somehow put it
all together and then when new writers
have been they like to add stuff into
that origin a great example is Black
Widow
they added in the whole thing with the
Red Room and the Black Widow project and
then you're supposed to go okay that
peppers in to what's already here and
that's been the problem of the marbles
since the dawn or whatever that's like
I'm on my channel we do the origins for
DC there are a lot more concise than we
do with the Marvel because with marble
it's 40 years because technically
everything that's happened is
technically a part of the origin so it's
like well there's no God I mean it'd be
different if they had the Marvel
unlimited app and they said okay here's
like Marvel unlimited for Doctor Doom
here's like a reading order to Doctor
Doom I mean right video about Doctor
Doom
I had to reference the doctor knew his
first appearance that came two years
after his original appearance in the
Fantastic Four
I had to reference his his origin story
which was given in Fantastic Four annual
number two or something like that
I had to cite the Doctor Doom and Doctor
Strange journey which is a really good
graphic novel but I had to cite that I
had to cite a couple stories that were
found scattered throughout Fantastic
Four I had to go through ed Brubaker's
run of the books of doom there were like
five or six different sources I had to
go to just to do the origin story of
Doctor Doom it's not like we need to
diverge for one second here because the
audience just noticed something and I'm
going to totally embarrass vows with
this Faust our banner you misspelled
weekly why would you I'm just like sick
why would you reveal that was me I feel
bad why would you like somebody somebody
in the chat like you know okay oh yeah
no one noticed in the last hour one
person which one of you guys there was
one of you guys in the chat one of you
guys sat down there and you said huh
that's that's Wilkie like wow I should
tell everybody
welcome to the Wilkey pool what correct
that guy in his defense he did do it
like cuz Joe wasn't gonna be here so he
literally did it like five minutes
before the podcast he was in hurry so
the fact that house even did it was
pretty amazing but blame it on one for
four people when we haven't plugged
custard for people you're gonna see that
one go wow that looks like an overlay
which one of you guys is a Chad so going
back to what I was about to say origins
it's not like they even do it for just
their main a list characters they've
done it for him
pixee because she originally started out
as just a mutant at the Xavier Institute
and like three years later on an off
comment they added in the fact that she
was Welsh and then she suddenly became
she was suddenly born in Wales as well
as being Welsh but from a mining town
and she was too scared of the mine which
is why she moved to America to go to the
Xavier Institute and then her father
wasn't actually from Wales and Bieber
was her mother and so she was masked
mines daughter and the masked mine
sisters were her half sisters yeah they
just keep adding stuff over the years
she's not British I mean that happened
then she's like she switches bodies and
now she's Asian you know and it's the
bad example is I mean it's just we have
we had that there's a debate over who
Scarlet Witch and quicksilver's parents
are that's the entire hat oh my god you
okay because I need to interrupt this
for a second that was the most
ridiculous thing I still have still
haven't gotten over this dad is okay -
imitates al for a second alright who was
thinking that I don't know what they
were thinking
somebody had to say like we've got to
find a way to make Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch the Inhumans sort of like
just do it like just just have really
like no no she okay there
okay let me tell you something that
they're not the children of Magneto she
cast the spell magneto doesn't collapse
and so they're like okay like like
you're not our Father
which was like the most ridiculous way
to reveal that I can guarantee you
they're going to say they're Inhumans
like that's gonna happen I mean it makes
sense I mean but I guess you could you
could tie into it if you did here would
be there's no this is one of those this
is one of those decision that Marvel
makes like from time to time normal
comes along it says let's make a
decision and what they do is they make a
decision that they can't recover from
there's no way to recover from this like
the accepted continuity for decades
twenty thirty years was that Quicksilver
and Scarlet Witch were the kids of
magneto that's fine if they want to
change that but one way they changed it
was dumb and to they're gonna change it
into something dumber they're gonna say
like they're gonna say they're in humans
because you've got them as in humans in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and stay
what you want hold on cuz they because
then I got a lot of flack for calling
them Inhumans in the movie in hands yeah
they're a hands now what I want to say
to that real quick everyone's like oh
they're not humans they're enhanced for
all we know they aren't humans and the
only reason that they survived the
sceptre is because they're in humans
they awoke some stories why Inhumans on
and except it's 10 minutes bout some
people haven't seen that we'll skip over
this we'll just we'll come back to that
but ok you know how I know when humans
are enhanced you know I know that
because one ok see this this is why I
like people so this is why it why it
amazes me people watched age at age of
Ultron and didn't like pay attention no
spoilers we're not going to go into it
in the ages of shield all Inhumans are
referred to as enhanced people every
every inhuman has ever been captured or
ever been in chronic where you know I
just categorize or whatever it is they
refer to them as enhanced people they
refer to sky ok he's awesome human but
he's got powers and they they refer to
sky as an enhanced person they have like
a litany of people that they they you
know consider to be enhanced people and
every single inhuman that we know of is
on that list it's a broad term it's not
a broad term it's a term for it no he's
right he's right because they refer to
everyone they don't have been calling
him in humans in the in the show right
now they're just like oh they were
enhanced individuals with our gifts have
come out they didn't call them in humans
okay they called him in humans like at
the the closing of the last show they
were like the agents of shield like
eight as a shield takes on the Inhumans
oh I know because when purple man shows
up in Jessica Jones alias there how are
they gonna explain his power they're
gonna say he's an inhuman or they just
gonna say he's enhanced and happens to
have the powers that he has powers
science say GLaDOS gave miss powers
which by the way it's like sidestep for
a second I can't wait for purple man
Jones a general yeah I'm like Jessica
Jones gonna be so bold choice making
that show the follow-up to daredevil
follow up that's I think I face would
have been a good transitional piece cuz
because it's the same kind of thing as
daredevil and we're kind of
transitioning more into because Jessica
Jones has less less power oriented a
more real life oriented yeah you know
yeah we'll get to see Luke Cage in that
show and then Luke Cage will get to spin
off into his own and then Luke Cage
transition to iron fist so I guess
that's what they were thinking but then
they should Jessica Jones first none of
them showed up in daredevil like did
nobody cameo in daredevil so oh we got
plenty of references though yeah but
like going going back to Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch I would be interested if
they made Scarlet Witch human but then
like Quicksilver a mutant or something
to me like that would be way more
interesting than they're both just
Inhumans are they're both mutants
because that would sort of play with
that dynamic where they've always been
sort of this shell that's together and
that will just kind of separate them off
that would get them there one unifying
factor and just break it and yeah
but Harkin alas you forget they have
they basically sowed the seeds for
Quicksilver being in a human in a
previous storyline if remember way
there's no little much like Lightspeed
time travel yes sir yeah they sow the
seeds and they said that like okay he
basically like developed enhanced
abilities from what he already had you
know with the Terrigen crystals now
granted he screwed everybody else up
they fold up that story in X Factor and
I thought that was very well handled
whatever oh I didn't see the follow up
to it an X Factor it's good you should
read X Factor Peter David it was really
good before our God canceled good he
taught in the 99 universe before it
ended that's weird
it was good but it's a good twist
actually the final issue he's like fine
that I won't get to do this twist I'm
just gonna do it right now then this is
what I was building up to everybody
oh okay so to keep our conversations
when we keep the podcast main topics
rolling forward let's I mean we talked
plenty about like all the secret Wars
theories and speculation and I mean we
don't have anything to work with so how
do you guys feel about the divergence
issue of DC pretty much stating
convergence doesn't matter because the
new 52 is gonna fight Darkseid on the
dark side Wars 140 Metro exactly the
anti-monitor and in their conversation
they say we fear that because of the
convergence Brainiac may learn the
secret of the DC universe and that is
that we are in a constant state of death
and rebirth the Darkseid war is
happening concurrently to convergence so
that's why the new 52 you guys are
probably not gonna show up in
convergence at all the weirdest thing
about convergence is that I feel like
convergence is not necessary they're
just like you remember that but weekly
series we had we're just continuing that
convergence oh you when you actually
have to read it Justice League which i
think is the weirdest thing they did not
promote that correct
obviously event and the other one didn't
I feel like I feel like earth to like I
feel
burdens and they didn't promote this at
all but is like the closing chapter to
the earth to saga that has been like a
total of about 80 freakin issues at this
point
okay just not even necessary at all
obviously at this point I don't want to
get hurt to society cuz I'm so done with
her to at this point to keep it going
like okay and because world's end led up
into converters let me ask you guys this
everybody who read world's head wasn't
it like halfway through that we were I
don't for me at least I was sitting
there like I know you're going to lose
the planet stop fighting and just end
this book I think after five going why
am i buying this series oh you're right
I have to review it I should say that
Benny cuz we're halfway through
convergence right now and my thing is
like oh so earth twos gonna win this
fight Telos is gonna make them a new
planet and that's where society is gonna
take place so you know I don't I don't
even like I'm sorry I'm sorry pals go
ahead I mean that's what's my you know
that my issue with afterworlds Anders
just kind of carried over into
convergence it's just they've got like
this much story and they're spreading
out this much they really are I mean
it's it's I stopped caring about
convergence after week - oh yeah like
the main story but the tie-ins are fine
right I want to say about virgins this
is just like week three but like the
week three tions didn't resonate with me
at all I was like I don't care about any
of these what era of a DC fan you are
like this week this last one was the
hardest one for me because it's like hey
guys infinity Inc like we got one of
their original creators back to write
this book uh-huh I'm like yeah that's
exactly what it was what you thought it
felt like trying to sell trying to sell
ketchup popsicles to a woman in white
gloves it's what is what this this week
felt like I mean like there's no Kenny 1
there have been some great aspects some
great times I loved like the pre
flashpoint Superman's story
it was like free flash point Superman
versus versus flashpoint like the whole
flashpoint group that was cool and I was
like I can't wait to get to issue number
two of this you know the one with Wally
West was and it was kind of cool but
that's Superman one really really tied
in with me America that was a pretty
good moment yeah oh my god that tugged
on the heartstrings what it was better
though was Batgirl yeah there was a
filling us in that apparently issue
seven of convergence is the official one
for the new 52 guys during the fight so
what that says to me is what's gonna
happen is earth Jews gonna fail and then
we need the real heroes to show my
question if if divergence is going to
revolve around dark side the dark side
wars does this mean divergence is gonna
turn into like a crisis and they're
going to like say okay from this point
going forward there's only just like
arbitrary stories and no realities yes
they're saying they're trying to avoid
they're saying if it happens again
everything will end they have to avoid
another crisis which feels like meta
commentary from Geoff Johns like our
universe see that I hate I hate things
like that because it sounds like a sales
pitch it sounds like oh my god we've got
all this in for inventory we gotta sell
sell sell you know it's like come buy
these cars for like three thousand
dollars off its what it feels like you
know is how it comes across and if DC
wants to do a crisis just come out and
say okay hey guys yes Convergys was a
filler divergence were leading to a
crisis and we're gonna reset everything
all over again except now the new 52 is
going to be one of a litany of realities
that we're gonna have now we're gonna
have Silver Age Superman stories so
we're gonna have you know like
flashpoint you know Green Lantern
stories and that's that's fantastic
because now you have something for
everybody rather than like trying to
force this one's you know one size fits
all category on fans you got fans that
grew up with Wally West I can go by
Wally West you got that as I grew up
with Kyle Rayner they didn't go by Kyle
Rayner he got fans who grew up with
Silver Age Superman thinking don't do
the same thing and I think that you know
diversifying their bonds
then sorry but that will go back to what
they were doing back in the Silver Age
because back in the Silver Age they had
multiple realities that they pretty much
did create a video of a continuity and
every year they had a yearly crisis
event that was like crisis of no f1
crisis and left to well like the
realities came together to defeat some
kind of evil in one year it was that
massive evil was three the so it just is
going back to what they were doing back
in the three always the enemy like is
always versions are it's the Alabama of
all the earth systems the backwards over
just that number three it's the problem
they had the probably DC had going into
the crisis on Infinite Earths
is they had no organization they were
just like a flash of two earths wow we
can do multiversal stories it's like
like you write a multiversal story and
you write a universe you get a universe
and everybody happens to have it so
close by just just write universes and
you know if it all pops off then we'll
just do a crisis and we'll just
consolidate everything that was a
problem that they had as nothing was
organized if they go into it now and
they say okay look crisis all these
different continuities but it's going to
be organized like we're only going to
have like 15 different continuities or
something like that then it would make
sense a problem that I think DC would
have is if they walked across that line
and if my cat said that that convergence
is like a testbed they're saying okay
like we have all these different like we
have every generation of DC Comics
basically being presented here which
ones are the most popular and we'll do
stories based on that inevitably there's
going to be that group of people that
say hey like like I want captain carrot
like with us captain carrot I don't
think anybody is asking for
speaking of things that people are
asking for and because I haven't
mentioned it in this podcast and I have
to mention at least once in every
podcast New Teen Titans sold really well
and sold out in pretty much every comic
store have our star in the UK Kate :
really music they will bring back the
New Teen Titans and they will force Marv
Wolfman to write a books were really
good both you know the New Teen Titans
and the other ones like where's Cassie
where's Tim I was like I want them to
write I want them but that you can only
really put Jeff Jones on them oh yeah
unless unless you call them Young
Justice Lake and down like there was
there was like the consensus that I can
understand who is I think I'm justice
would sell better because of the whole
TV show people would want it and then
you have the New Teen Titans you got
Young Justice and everyone's happy but
then at the same time the Young Justice
comics was so different from the comedy
they were oh yeah I enjoyed those books
I prefer the coming to the cartoon I
have things to say about the cartoon
that people don't know about you picked
the wrong group with me and cat here you
hold them all hit up I want to see that
New York comic-con I want it like we
have to get that on like an iPhone like
I want to see you all in cat beating
I'll protect you don't worry I got your
back buddy to Greg Weisman Cultus over
I'll be recording the whole thing with
my iPhone all right guys so we're kind
of winding down the actual podcast we're
gonna start doing our exit remarks
please stick around the pond of a the
stream we'll be hanging around
afterwards when the podcast officially
ends if you're watching this post on
Rob's channel make sure you come check
out our twitch twitch TV backslash
eligible monster I know the name makes
no sense
but that's where it is been at wish-tv
backslash eligible monster that's where
you can be live at the chat and see the
post show and the pre-show so let's kind
of close down here please chat don't
leave we're gonna be hanging around a
little bit longer afterwards where you
can see Joel and Kat beating up Faust
and Faust crying for his mommy it's
gonna be funny he says he likes a
cartoon better
exactly we take cartoons very seriously
around here don't you know so as usual
at the end of every episode we always
kind of go over what we're planning for
our channels for me I'm just doing World
War Hulk at the end of this week and I
don't even know we're doing next week DC
again because we've done Marvel for like
three weeks now so I'll be doing DC
again next week yeah I was thinking the
same thing like I want to do a history
like some something I'm not the Lantern
Corps I might just do 90 owls death in
the family and then jump into endgame so
okay and that's what's going on comics
aflame he's kind of like me we're all
just kind of like we're gonna do videos
faster than Joel and then we'll end with
comic you know so you get the most time
to plug your channel cap and fast what
do you got going on this week over at
it's super effective this week we have
some highlights from Grant Morrison's
Korea very excited about that because
Grant Morrison is my favorite writer
then we've got a history of Young
Avengers looking at very specific story
arc and other than that I have no idea
all right Joe what's going on with the
comic book cast 40-man team this week we
probably did more like live-action
videos like the stuff we're doing out
than we ever have before I covered the
Ultron initiative cuz you know hey
Ultron wanted to get in on that that's
the story where Ultron turns Tony Stark
into a woman and steals his body oh my
god that's one in Frank I did always
kind of baffled me how come I get I get
taking over Tony Stark's body I get all
of that stuff why did it turn I mean I
get he wants him to look like Janet but
that should not have just been oh I want
you to be a woman I will watch your
coverage on that they never explain it
but it's Frank Cho's artwork in his
artwork is asked
also you can watch a free comic book day
video I did I went to towns over to my
nearest comic shop and I talked to the
owners and I did some stuff there and I
picked up some books and that was fun
oh we have our own age of Ultron
discussion that that just went up today
we talked about that and broke that down
just a bunch of different reviews and
stuff all the audience is pretty much
breaking this down for you Joel they're
saying that next week 100 videos from
comic book cast do it bad we couldn't no
we're trying to pull back we're trying
to do good but yeah we did that of
course podcast every week we're gonna be
jumping into Secret Wars be sure to come
by the channel on Wednesday I mean that
are probably gonna rush that one out
right away I mean you know like you know
they said the issue number two is gonna
be huge it's gonna be like the tour of
all the worlds interesting yeah it's
gonna be nuts I'm down it and our
moderator Goldman Goldman vision if you
could actually link their channels and
that'd be great and oh it might take you
a minute but uh oh and let's go ahead
and end with comic dunno why don't you
explain what you do on your channel what
you who you are cuz the first time
you've been on the weekly poll even
though you've been contributing articles
for quite a while to the website now um
why don't you just kind of explain
yourself in full let's let's get the cat
awesome I am the cat um so my channel I
cover comic book stuff so I usually do
good night in-depth reviews and also TV
shows I cover arrow flash flash should
be up right after this other TV shows to
you so you go check that out
also have a group channel called comic
frontline which we're doing a live show
at 9:30 so that's gonna be our con book
podcast then also I have a TV movie
podcast over there too which is media
madness which joel's been on a couple of
times and that's usually 10 o'clock p.m.
Eastern Time we're going to be talking
Avengers that Thursday for that on comic
Frontline also just put an interview up
with sterling gates about posting so
that was a lot of fun um I'll sign my
own comic book like father like daughter
so if you guys want to go check that out
it's still we're still figuring out how
we're gonna put it out digitally and all
that so it might be a couple more weeks
for that but you go check it out and on
my twitter and facebook comic you know
you could go check all those stuff out
so comic books and TV stuff that's what
i
awesome alright guys thank you for
joining us for today's podcast make sure
you come back at the same time tomorrow
where we're gonna have our spoiler cast
of the weekly polls just discussions of
age of Ultron we're gonna get as many
comic book youtubers as we can on here
Faust I'll have a heart attack when I'm
like Faust I need I need a thing with 9
panels exactly so you don't forget to
stick around we're only gonna be ending
the official podcast that's going up on
Rob's channel so you if we're gonna do a
quick commercial break after this and
then we'll all be here to answer a few
questions chitchat and have a little bit
of fun but just all need to get a little
drink and I need to use the restroom so
thank you guys for joining us it's tick
read a lot of the commercial break and
we will be back shortly I gotta use a
little boy regular shirt is my phone I
got freaking creditors calling me who
I've been dodging I'm still live so
don't tell them that you're dodging yet
hold on we haven't gone on everything oh
no they're watching thank you so much
we'll be back in two minutes just to
chitchat with all of you cool